a Restaurant Row in North Las Vegas is
starting to take shape it'll be on Craig
Road between North 5th Street and then
running out to Losi Sasha Loftus joins
us from that area with more on what this
is bringing to that part of town
this Freddy's custard behind me just one
of many along what is now dubbed
Restaurant Row here in North Las Vegas
this all coming as the city continues to
expand quickly it's just exciting it's
no secret North Las Vegas is booming as
things grow you know
people get better opportunities you know
right now jobs are available and with
that
that Grumps more business
opportunity
and North fifth now dubbed Restaurant
Row
the corridor touts 17 new fast food
locations dining spots bars and coffee
shops including a brand new Raising
Cane's so we're just super excited to
bring this out here regional vice
president Stephen short says this
location which opened its doors on
Thursday is a great way for the company
to jump in
as North Las Vegas ranks fifth in the
country in greatest population growth
adding just under 10 000 people since
2020. there's a new restaurant popping
up on every corner we wanted to make
sure that we were a part of that growth
all while those who've been here for
decades say they're glad to see things
moving and changing in the right way
it's been a challenge but at the end of
the day you know growth is important now
those at Raising Canes tell me their new
location off of Craig and Allen is
bringing over 100 new jobs here to the
north Las Vegas area reporting in North
Las Vegas tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News
Now